on se connaît je m'appelle drouagle je
suis le père de Shannon la copine de
Jamie je suis la mère de Jimmy on adore
Shannon
je trouve que ce que vous faites c'est
vraiment intéressant tu veux investir
dans WMV on transfère des fonds
invisibles dans des marchés invisibles à
des vitesses invisibles
le minimum est de 300 300000 oui qui ne
risque rien n'a rien pas vrai on s'en
sortira comment on l'a toujours fait
j'ai entré chez moi oui
ça va je vais bien tu as conduit en état
d'ivresse hier soir j'en sais rien il y
a quelqu'un qui l'a ramené après la fête
qui ça
de toute évidence
la question c'est qui va avoir des
ennuis maintenant lui ou toi
la valeur de ton investissement a baissé
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans l'ordre
naturel des choses
je suis pas fait pour ça que il faut que
je récupère mon argent tu fous le camp
de ma propriété
on doit tous faire des sacrifices je
peux pas être mêlé une espèce de
conspiration
alors tu as fini par fuguer j'avais
juste envie de te voir avant vous voulez
quoi je peux vous fournir des
informations qui s'ouvrent votre fils
nous avons un témoin
il faut que je récupère mon argent et
pas un jeu de groupe
[Musique]
et qu'est-ce que tu fous Hollywood tu es
venu pour acheter de l'herbe
[Musique]
je fais le montage de ce film
c'est un autiste du 7e art qui veut dire
qu'il vit respire les films et je suis
presque certain qu'il est encore plus
chaud j'ai eu une idée sur un grand
requin blanc qui terrorise une ville de
la côte genre une ville de nouvel
Angleterre un robot requin quoi
[Musique]
j'ai entendu dire que c'était une garce
je veux aller lui parler son copain a
prévu LSD lui a mordu le nez alors elle
a sauté par la fenêtre
bienvenue à Hollywood petit
tu veux bien m'apprendre
sur un projet je vais monter votre film
qu'est-ce que ça fait de me voir mourir
j'adore te voir mourir parce que je peux
te ramener à la vie j'ai écrit un fil de
guerre cauchemardesque la palme armée où
il y a que des sauvages drogue on est au
cœur des ténèbres si tu vois ce que je
veux dire on a besoin de quelqu'un pour
un premier montage sur le terrain les
délais tu as un passeport mon grand j'ai
l'impression que ta carrière est
vraiment en train de décoller
du temps
[Musique]
tu veux dire si je savais que ça allait
devenir un film génial
ton cadeau je t'offre quelque chose de
spécial pour fêter ça donc ils ont bien
tu vas t'éclater ce soir
tout le monde est heureux à présent
chacun est à sa place il y a
soyez les bienvenus dans la réserve
il y a pas de souffrance là-bas de John
chacun est à sa place nul n'est jamais
seul c'est ce que j'ai toujours voulu
pour toi vous êtes ici chez vous
à présent et laissez-le vous
transmettre on n'est jamais seul ici
tout le monde est connecté
quelqu'un comme vous pour le guider pour
l'intégrer au corps social vous pouvez
échapper à votre conditionnement comme
nous tous et de ce que vous verrez ne
sera plus jamais comme avant
c'est vrai que tu connais le sauvage si
personne s'en rend compte de la chance
que vous avez la vie de tout le monde
est parfaite ce n'est pas réel de quoi
parlez-vous
de tous qu'est-ce qui se passe
si vous arrêtez d'en prendre vous
pourriez découvrir ce que vous ressentez
on doit arrêter le sauvage avant que
cela ne dépasse ce qu'ils vous ont fait
est inconcevable
ce qu'il vous feront inimaginable
on va crever si on reste ici
tu n'es pas heureux
tu n'es rien du tout
dans le monde
[Musique]
salut
je te souhaite une belle journée tu vas
ressembler à toutes les autres
ça va vous m'entendez j'ai une formation
de secouriste
[Musique]
on a fait son bi ça n'existe pas alors
pour toi là ça c'est parfaitement normal
[Musique]
il n'est pas question qu'on ouvre les
portes ma fille est là dehors
je vais revoir mon père figure-toi mais
comment on va passer à travers les
zombies je viens d'avoir une idée de ouf
alors pour toi c'est ça une idée de ouf
salut bande de looser
[Musique]
tu fais comment fais comme dans les
films explosent leur maternelle
si on passe par là on sera au lycée
avant qu'il fasse nuit il peut même
qu'on se marre bien une mort certaine
c'est super marrant
c'est possible en fait
[Musique]
allez allez allez allez allez allez
allez allez allez allez
[Musique]
sinon essaye une recherche avec hashtag
évacuation selfie moi je dis qu'on
mérite de disparaître
[Musique]
la bombe celui-là ça ressemble à des
gribouillis et des [ __ ] sur une toile
vierge que c'est un peu ça la vie c'est
juste un tas de gribouillis de queue et
de violence dans le néant
de ma sœur il était le mec il faut
toujours branler avant d'aller baiser
une meuf je me suis branlé avant de
venir je dois toujours être prêt j'ai
jamais où je vais finir la soirée et il
m'a donné le sentiment d'en être un tube
[Musique]
une seconde qu'il va finir par ce
pointer devant chez toi dans sa caisse
tous les jours jusqu'à la fin de ta vie
[Musique]
tu devrais te faire des amis de ton âge
quoi
[Musique]
c'est trop mortel tu devrais aller
vendre ma beuh à ta fête attends tu
crois que je vais me pointer avec ton
matos et qui vont tous vouloir m'en
acheter dit que je suis dingue aussi
cette meuf elle a 16 ans en tout cassée
nique j'ai 16 ans ouais je sais quoi
[Musique]
tous les gamins font des erreurs c'est
justement l'intérêt d'en être un
[Musique]
je crois que le revenu pour toi
c'est un tatouage permanent sur ton
torse c'est ça je peux savoir ce que ça
veut dire oh [ __ ]
[Musique]
bien souvent en regardant en arrière on
se demande le jeu en valait-il la
chandelle
les récentes découvertes valaient-elles
tant d'effort un calculable et tout ce
qui a été sacrifié au nom de la victoire
vous recevez annulez immédiatement
l'atterrissage c'est un ordre
et ce qui nous a mené à la victoire la
soif de connaissance ou l'insatiable
vanité
aujourd'hui à 17h30 heure locale un
cataclysme a eu lieu à la surface de
Mars
est-ce que vous réalisez ce qui s'est
passé on ignore combien de temps il lui
reste encore à vivre
désormais mars est devenu une
destination pour satisfaire notre
curiosité
[Musique]
le seul moyen de se protéger de cette
vérité
c'est de t'éliminer
n'oublie pas tu es Spider-Man
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]